i have something very special planned
that might help my relationship with
vanessa
the hotel i picked out is literally a
castle
oh my god this is adorable
wow look at the dragon i love stories i
love fairy tales and
i've always been kind of nerdy growing
up kind of stayed home a lot played
video games
i thought this would be a great escape
from reality hello
my name is shannon i'm your fairy queen
and i'd love to welcome you to come live
your fairy tale
well we we would love that just this way
the castle awaits
such a fine lord bringing the luggage up
i'm learning
go ahead my lady thank you darlin
oh wow holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
wow
i want to show vanessa that she's my
queen what better place than a castle
i think it's pretty cool the keys to
your castle thank you
if you have a wondrous day this is way
more elaborate than i thought the
pictures don't do it justice
oh holy cow oh my god
now this is a bedroom look at this oh my
god
wow this is beautiful
oh this is interesting
wanna play dress up can we wear these
yeah it says you can this place is
amazing
i didn't expect him to go all out like
this
i like that he's very creative with his
dates the bungee jumping the castle here
it's no one's ever done anything like
this for me
i oh
[Music]
hello what's going on there this
is an interesting role play i mean i
like the view personally yeah
you look pretty good yourself kingsley
very beautiful no actually this is
pretty sexy dude
no look at that
i'm into role-playing but i've never
experienced something like this before
i feel like i'm like the uh the peasant
that's trying to be a knight or
something
a squire i don't have a noble background
but i'm trying to make my way in this
[Music]
world